i
interviewed a guy a couple weeks ago was
a cardiologist
and he has done 25 000 hearts surgeries
okay and this last week i interviewed
cyril wecht i don't know if you guys
know what cyril wecht is
sarah white is a number one pathologist
in america he's the guy that
he's he's done 21 000 autopsies okay
brains
and he supervised 41 000 of it you know
what's part of his game
it's the whole brains and to deal with
dead people you know what's a part of a
cardiologist job
unfortunately his job is to sometimes go
to families and say what
we lost your father we lost your auntie
we lost your mom we lost your dad we
lost your husband we lost your wife we
lost your kid
and guess how many times the first time
you do it painful
10th time painful 50th time
painful by the 500 time
it's the career you chose some surgeries
don't go right
and you have to go deliver the news i'm
sorry but we lost your father
you ever seen a movie uh uh john q
where the whole heart thing and you saw
one of the heart surgeons in the movie
john q with denzel washington
where the way the doctor speaks he's so
logical i don't know if you guys know
what i'm talking about
yes okay so here's what we got going on
we got this and the way they speak is
very matter of fact
and the rest of the world is like what a
cold mother you know what
how could you be this cold this is
someone's life
because that's his job his job is
people die okay and the first one sucks
the fifth one sucks the tenth one sucks
by the fiftieth one is the career you
chose right okay
what does that have to do with you
um in football when there's a massive
injury in a game players psychologically
get afraid
if you if you look at football like
coaches and great coaches in that moment
have to get their players to realize
this is the game we signed up for you
could get hurt
but if you play right or not if you play
afraid of being injured the chance of
you getting injured goes higher
if you play as if you're not going to
get injured the chance of you getting
injured goes lower
that moment what the coach tells us
athletes
is what gets the players to go back out
there and play after a guy just broke
his leg he's gone for one year
it's that few right kobe came back after
having the whole achilles heel and how
does he go back
it's the game we signed up for and the
game we all signed up for is what it's
called life
people are going to die if you play the
game of business it's going to be
enemies there's going to be people that
want to
see you go out of business it's a part
of life so i i
i i don't want to seem like i'm not
being empathetic or sympathetic
believe me i cried when i'm sitting
there and watching my wife cry of course
i cry
it's painful i get it but we signed up
and we're in this life okay and however
many years ago all our parents conceived
and nine months later we're here some of
us are accidents
some of us are intentional but guess
what we're now here okay
and we got around eight years to see
what we can do with our lives nothing's
guaranteed
we got to give our best but i want you
to know and this message goes to
everybody
is grace for impact there's going to be
some bad things that are going to happen
to you in 2021
not trying to be negative there's going
to be some bad things that are going to
happen to you
there's going to be some things that are
going to happen to you that you don't
know about my dad's 78
he's not going to live 200 years old
something's going to happen to me i'm no
longer 22 i'm 42.
okay i got three kids they're gonna get
into fight injuries something like that
i don't have one kid i don't have zero
kids i told a guy the other day
when the whole jack ma was being uh uh
kidnapped
in in china is he kidnapped is he this
is he that what happened to jack ma
i said you know what's one of the uh one
of the biggest mistakes people make in
life
that gives an automatic control to
politicians to be able to manipulate you
for the rest of your life what's that
having kids why because
if people want to really hurt you they
go straight to what
kids like in politics if you don't do
this
this is what's going to happen to your
kids how do they eliminate the kennedy
family they went straight after their
kids
so what's the point we all made the
decision
to be married if we are your heart's
going to be broken if you have kids
something could happen to your kid if
you eat the food and it's too much sugar
bad diet you may have something to do
with your heart
everything is a decision that we're
making and we got to do our best to live
with this
now here's also some guaranteed news
about 2021 there's going to be some
great things that are going to happen to
you in 2021
new surprises you're going to meet
someone they knew that you didn't know
before that's going to change your life
a new friend a new contact a new client
a new sales person a new employee
something good is going to happen a lot
of good is going to happen to you and
that's going to happen
every single year for the rest of our
lives
until it's time for us to go away that's
kind of how life works
but if you wake up every morning afraid
that
you know what if this what if that and
oh my gosh sorry me
feel sorry for me you are going to stun
so much of your growth
because that's not going away and
everybody else in the world
is dealing with their own set of
problems
i read a quote one time 80 percent of
people could care less about your
problems
twenty percent of people are glad you
have them
very simple eighty percent could care
less about your problems
twenty percent of your people are glad
you have an exes
former friends former employees
former workers are glad you're getting
your problems you got to live your life
and you do your best and good things
will happen to you so you just got a
sneak little pig from an episode that i
did in this video if you want to see the
full episode click over here to watch
the entire episode
and if you've not subscribed to this
channel please do so take care everybody